you
we go Rises hira dawn is simultaneously
a role-playing game that plays like an
action game we're known for our first
person shooter series kill zone and well
storytelling in an open world and in an
RPG is not something that we had done
before but I think all of us we really
welcome it as just a wonderful
opportunity to create something that's
so fresh so new it's a wonderful
challenge for us
this game has a lot of different eco
tops as we call them each of the Eco
tops home with our own machines to
discover and their own machines baking
with their own behaviors and what
they're doing in that environment we've
shown at e3 baby are sort of more force
T full like environments but we also
have deserts in the game we have high
mountain peaks called completely covered
in snow we have jungle in the game we
have lots of different environments and
of course a really big part of it is
also the ancient ruins that we have in
the game which are again a completely
different sort of atmosphere setting so
the game has a full day night cycle but
on top of that there's also a very
dynamic weather system so you get the
types of weathers that belong to certain
Iquitos and that of course also has an
influence on the gameplay it reduces
visibility or make certain things harder
certain things might also be easier so
there is a large component of how the
look and the weather and the day cycle
but impacts your experience as a player
the transition from kills 02 horizon has
been really interesting both from an
artistic point of view as well as
technically when we're my rifle kills
over making linear levels or serpent
Knight levels maybe you walk through
them but we have very tight control and
that's completely different than the
open world but the player has a lot more
freedom to approach things the way that
they want to see it so we really had the
baby start looking at the world from a
360 point of view maybe looking at all
the different directions to the player
could approach how things would look
mega revistas would look and all these
different aspects
you
those things